- [Instructor] For this problem,
our goal is to figure out
whether or not a precipitate will form
if we mix 0.20 liters over
4.0 times 10 to the negative
third Molar solution of lead two nitrate,
with 0.80 liters of an 8.0
times 10 to the negative third
Molar solution of sodium sulfate.
The first step is to
figure out the identity
of the precipitate that might form.
So we're mixing an aqueous
solution of lead two nitrate
with an aqueous solution
of sodium sulfate.
In the lead two nitrate
solution they're lead two plus
cations and nitrate anions.
In the sodium sulfate aqueous solution,
there are sodium cations
and sulfate anions.
So we take the cation from one
and the anion from the other.
So one possible product
would be lead sulfate.
So let's write on here,
PbSO4, after we cross over
our charges and we take the
other cation and the other anion
and so the other product
would be sodium nitrate.
So we write it in here and a NaNO3.
To balance the equation, we
need a two in front of NANO3.
Since nitrates are soluble,
sodium nitrate is an aqueous
solution and lead sulfate would
be our possible precipitate.
Now that we know are possible precipitate,
let's go ahead and write
a net ionic equation
showing the formation of that precipitate.
So lead two plus ions, would
come together with sulfate
anions to form PBSO4.
So PBSO4 is the possible precipitate.
Since lead sulfate is
our possible precipitate,
we really only care about the
concentration of lead two plus
ions and sulfate anions in solution.
We don't need to worry about
sodium cations or nitrate
anions because those
are the spectator ions
in our overall reaction.
Running the overall equation,
and the net ionic equation
are really optional for
a problem like this.
But we really need to do
is identify the precipitate
and then write out the
disillusion equation.
So PBSO4 would be our
possible precipitate.
And if it dissolves in water,
we would form lead two plus
cations in aqueous solution,
and sulfates anions
in aqueous solutions, right?
aq over here.
The reason why it's important
to write out the dissolution
equation is because we
can write a KSP expression
from it.
So KSP is equal to, it
would be the concentration
of lead two plus raised to the first power
because we have a coefficient of one
in the balanced equation,
times the concentration
of sulfate also raised
to the first power and
pure solids are left out
of equilibrium, constant expressions.
Therefore we're not going
to include lead sulfate.
For lead two sulfate KSP
is equal to 6.3 times 10
to the negative seven
at 25 degrees Celsius.
The concentrations of lead two
plus and sulfate in the KSP
expression, are
equilibrium concentrations.
For our problem, we're
gonna calculate QSP,
which has the same form as KSP,
the differences the concentrations can be
at any moment in time.
And we're gonna calculate
QSP at the moment,
our two solutions are mixed,
and then we're going
to compare QSP to KSP.
I've drawn out some diagrams
to help us understand
how QSP compares to
KSP and what that means
for the solution.
However, these aren't perfect diagrams
they're just to help get the point across.
If QSP is less than KSP,
the solution is unsaturated,
which means no precipitate would form.
For an unsaturated solution,
you can dissolve more
led two sulfate in it.
So lead two sulfate as a white solid,
so if we were to put a small
amount of lead two sulfate
in our unsaturated
solution, it would dissolve,
and it would continue to dissolve
until QSP is equal to KSP.
And the system is at equilibrium.
At equilibrium, the solid
is turning into the ions
at the same rate, the ions are
turning back into the solid.
Since the rate of dissolution
is equal to the rate
of precipitation when the
system is at equilibrium,
the concentrations of lead two plus ions
and sulfate ions are constant,
and this represents a saturated solution.
And since the solution is
saturated at equilibrium,
if we tried to add some
more lead two sulfate
at the same temperature,
we wouldn't be able to dissolve any more,
we would just increase the
pile of lead two sulfate
on the bottom of the beaker.
That concept helps us
understand what happens when QSP
is greater than KSP.
When QSP is greater than KSP,
the solution is oversaturated.
So it's exceeded the limit
of what can dissolve,
and therefore you can imagine
some lead two plus ions
combining with some sulfate
ions to form a precipitate.
Therefore, when QSP is greater than KSP,
a precipitate will form.
The precipitate will continue to form,
until QSP is equal to KSP,
and the system reaches equilibrium.
Next, we need to go back
to what we were given
in our initial problem,
when we mixed our two solutions together.
Remember we only cared about
the concentration of lead
two plus ions and sulfate ions.
So we're gonna calculate the
concentration of those two ions
at the moment in time, when
the two solutions are mixed.
First let's calculate the
concentration of lead two
plus ions.
The original solution of lead two nitrate
had a concentration of 4.0
times 10 to the negative
third Molar.
So molarity is equal to moles over liters.
So we can plug in the concentration,
and we can also plug in the
volume of that solution,
which was 0.20 liters, and solve for X,
X equal to 8.0 times 10 to
the negative fourth moles.
That's how many moles of lead two nitrate
there are and that's also
how many moles of lead two
plus ions there are.
Therefore to find the
concentration of lead two plus ions
after the solutions are mixed,
we plug in 8.0 times 10 to
the negative fourth moles,
and for the volume we're
adding these two solutions
together, so the total
volume of the solution
is 0.20 plus 0.80.
So the concentration of lead two plus ions
will be equal to 8.0 times 10
to the negative fourth Molar.
We can do the same type of calculation
to find the concentration of sulfate ions
after the two solutions have been mixed.
So we take the concentration
of the original solution
of sodium sulfate and plug that
into the molarity equation,
plug in the volume solve for
X and 6.4 times 10 to negative
third moles is how many moles
of sodium sulfate there are.
That's also how many moles
of sulfate ions there are,
so we plug in that number
into the concentration
for sulfate, and once
again, since we're adding
the two solutions together,
we divide that by the total
volume to get a
concentration of sulfate ions
of 6.4 times 10 to the
negative third Molar.
Now that we know the concentrations
of lead two plus ions
and sulfate ions, after the
two solutions have been mixed,
we can plug those concentrations
into our QSP expression
and solve for QSP.
So at this moment in time,
QSP is equal to 5.1 times 10
to the negative six.
At 25 degrees Celsius, the
KSP value for lead two sulfate
is equal to 6.3 times 10
to the negative seventh.
QSP at this moment in time is 5.1 times 10
to the negative six.
Therefore QSP is greater than KSP.
Since QSP is greater than
KSP, we've exceeded the limit
of what can dissolve and
therefore the solution
is oversaturated.
So yes, a precipitate will
form and the precipitate
of lead two sulfate will continue to form
until QSP is equal to KSP.